the beauty of a Costa Rican
rainforest a Place full of
life and
[Music]
death in a single
night nightmarish
Hunters stalk the
darkness armed with everything from
dagger-like
claws to poisonous secretion
they're ready to
strike ready to
feed ready to make a colorful and dense
Wilderness run red with
[Music]
blood
the rainforest of Costa
Rica are
alive like a bustling human
City every square inch of this
Wilderness is crowded with a wide
variety of animal
life and for the creatures that live
here maintaining one's personal space
can be a
[Music]
challenge and you never know who you'll
bump
[Music]
into with all these neighbors living
together in such close proximity
confrontations break out in a blink of
an
eye especially in the
dark
with the sun setting on the horizon
another countdown until dawn
begins once Darkness Falls some of the
most dangerous characters in this jungle
Metropolis emerg to do their
business
[Music]
one of the strangest neighborhoods is
the highrises of the forest
[Music]
canopy a woolly possum navigates this
Maze of branches sneaking through the
Shadows while keeping an eye out for
predators
[Music]
the Mean Streets of the forest floor are
so dangerous that many creatures have
evolved to spend the majority of their
lives in the
[Music]
trees from aggressive
jagari to over species of venomous
snakes leaving the branches can be a
death
sentence and while no neighborhood in
the rainforest is safe these araral
animals prefer taking their
chances in the
trees
and one of them spends the night looking
for something very
specific the
kinku a tree bound mammal who only grows
to be 2 ft
long but even though he's small he's not
afraid of the
dark especially when it holds the
promise of a delicious
treat he sniffs the air looking for a
fix on a sweet nectar of flowering
plants
these jewels of the forest are
irresistible to a king ofu with a sweet
tooth it's a winwin for both plant and
animal because as he feeds on the sugar
dealing flowers they transfer pollen
onto his fur which he'll spread
throughout the
forest
but his sugar addiction could get him in
trouble snakes utilize the plant life of
the canopy for entirely different
reasons and they perch in strategic
positions that they know prey will pass
by every night the kingu plays The
Deadly game of Russian
Roulette going from one potentially
lethal flower to another for his
fix
[Music]
the kingu ner escaped a strike from an
eyelash bit
Viper
these venomous araral snakes are known
for their eyelash like scales above
their eyes in a wide range of bright
colors which are thought to help them
blend in with the Alleyways of the
[Music]
trees while a kingu isn't on their
menu a defensive strike from an eyelash
pit viper could kill him
nonetheless he got lucky but the night
is still
young and for the eyeless
vipers The Hunt is just
beginning
[Music]
against a noisy backdrop of another
jungle KN these flowers remain quiet
hubs of insect
activity which attract others from far
and
wide
including this hungry
[Music]
gecko all the eyas pit viper has to do
is sit and
wait
[Applause]
[Music]
death hides in the beauty of a Costa
Rican
[Music]
rainforest
the eyelash pit viper strikes with
lethal
Precision wiing herself fresh gecko for
dinner her Venom floods through the
gecko's veins destroying the gecko's red
blood cells and Dam damaging its
muscles the eyelash pit viper lives her
entire life in the
trees so she maintains a tight grip on
her prey to avoid losing it to the
forest
[Music]
floor
using her long
fangs she Maneuvers her meal into
position so she can swallow it head
[Music]
first the gecko's fate serves as a
reminder to other tree
dwellers even high off the forest floor
no one's
safe
[Applause]
[Music]
while the Vipers of the trees wait for
their meals to come to
them down on the fourth
floor another Predator
searches for
his this sturdy ground dweller only
grows to be 2 ft
long but he's
fearless and he'll eat just about
[Music]
anything this is a greater
Gren he covers the terrain in a zigzag
pattern sniffing as he goes leaving No
Leaf or stone unturned in his endless
search for
food and in this crowded animal Metropol
was it's only a matter of time before he
finds someone to
hunt but this is no normal
frog
[Music]
the Gren catches up with his
Target one of the strangest frog species
on the
planet the Smoky jungle
frog this large
amphibian possesses many tricks to ward
off
attackers first she admits a croak that
sounds like a cat to confuse the
GM for a second trick she Rises on her
legs to create the illusion that she's
bigger than she
is but these Bluffs aren't enough to
keep the relen is gr at
Bay
so she resorts to her final
trick her skin emits a noxious toxin
that hurts to
breathe the Gren Retreats into the
forest in search of an easier
meal
with Dawn more than 6 hours away the
Gren will have other chances to
feed but for one of the smallest and
strangest predators in the forest 6
hours is in
eternity this
is the wolf
snail and she's a
cannibal every night she hungers for the
Flesh of her own
kind
and she hunts them by tracking the Slime
Trails they leave
[Music]
behind she zero in on a juicy
Target but hunting at a snail's pace has
its
disadvantages and unbeknown to her
another Predator is closing
in one who also has a taste for
escaro
[Music]
in this
rainforest even calistic Killers can
become the
haunted with 6 hours till
sunrise a wolf sale stalks others of her
kind unaware that another Predator
is tracking
her this is the Cloudy snail
eater and he specializes in hunting
slugs and
snails
he tracks the wolf snail onto a Mossy
Mound and Maneuvers into position to
intercept his
[Music]
prey the snow eater remains completely
still waiting for his Target to come
just a little
closer his patience pays off and the
snail climbs right onto his
back but even at this range the snake
has to wait for the perfect moment to
strike wolf snails are some of the
fastest gastropods on the
planet and they can quickly retract
their heads to avoid
strikes to prevent the snake from
getting another shot she climbs onto his
head her daring defense
works and while he works to regain his
composure she makes her
Escape
but it's not long before he's distracted
by another
Target a fat juicy
[Music]
slug
and he finally wins a
meal the wolf snail has dodged
death but her Escape leads her into
strange new
terrain she's not the only creature in
the forest moving at a snail's
[Music]
pace this is a tw- toad
sloth with a top speed of 8 ft per
minute he's one of the slowest animals
in the
forest
[Music]
his slimy hitchhiker hangs on for the
slowest ride of her
life as he travels to the vegetation he
devours for
dinner this low calorie diet demands
that he conserve energy however
[Music]
possible
for the
snail it's an unexpected trip to a new
part of the
forest and as her ride makes a pit stop
she disembarks to continue her
[Music]
hunt SLO rarely descend to the forest
floor because of all the danger it
hes leaving the safety of the trees is
only RIS when absolutely
necessary for the two toad
sloth this happens once a
week when Nature
[Music]
Calls unfortunately for the sloth the
restrooms here are very
public
and he has to do his business out in the
open where all his neighbors can
see even the more dangerous
ones out here getting caught with your
pants down can cost you your
life and is about to hit the
fan
a Tut toot sloth is risking his life to
take a bathroom
break this is one of the only reasons he
ever descends from the
trees because the forest floor of a
Costa Rican
rainforest is were some of the deadliest
predators in the world
hunt
and one of
them approaches in the
shadows this cat is a master of
stealth and while she isn't as big as a
Jaguar she's just as
ferocious the ocelot
a jungle cat with Advanced binocular
night
vision in the Moonlight the sloth sticks
out like a sore
thumb a big Target for a small
ocelot but one she can't
resist her best hope for success is to
maintain the element of
[Music]
surprise
the ocelas misstep alerts a troop of
howler
monkeys and these defensive prats have
learned to use weapons throwing branches
at any threat in their
area
the ocelot retreats to safeer hunting
[Music]
rounds with a neighborhood watch like
this the sloth can safely return to the
trees
fully
relieved but the flying branches aren't
welome by
everyone this Gladiator tree frog can
leap distances more than 30 times its
body length this Mill uses his spring to
escape the chaos
[Music]
but there are far worse things in this
jungle like the deadliest snake in Costa
Rica the fur
delance the Gladiator frog freezes to
avoid
detection
but with death closing
in he has to make a choice
between fight or
[Music]
flight the ference can only watch as a
frog escapes back into the
trees only two hours of night remain and
day Walkers try to get a little more
rest Before
[Music]
Sunrise but this ring for us never
sleeps and and some of the busiest
creatures here work around the
clock and they make the very trees
Ripple with
energy billions of termites live here
and they labor insistently to devour
[Music]
wood but this massive Colony has no idea
their world is about to be torn
apart thousands of lives are about the
end as one of the strangest predators in
Costa
Rica approaches a massive termite colony
this is the
tandura a creature with the singular
Devotion to hunting
termites and their kind
he rips into their nest with ravenous
enthusiasm and while he doesn't have
teeth he doesn't need them because his
foot long tongue is perfectly designed
for slurping up
bugs the insector has his
fil and the termites finally only get a
reprieve from his
invasion the tamadur has poor
iight so he relies on his sense of smell
to navigate through the thick
[Music]
jungle and while he's well adapted for
hunting
termites with no teeth and poor
vision he's especially vulnerable to
others
including a predator who is still on the
hunt the
[Music]
Grom but the tandura has a nasty
surprise for anyone he perceives as a
threat the odd looking furball is armed
and
dangerous massive 4inch Long Claws grow
from the third digit on each of his
paws and they're sharp enough to dismal
anything that comes too close
the Grom gets the message and we'll have
to go a little longer without a
[Music]
meal the tamu's claws have another
advantage and he uses them to climb back
into the relative safety of the trees
with only an hour left to Sunrise many
rainforest creatures hang on to whatever
they can for
safety but some do so in a stranger
fashion than
[Music]
others these gelatinous
blobs are alive
these are frog
eggs this gelatinous coating offers
limited protection to the Frog spawn
inside while allowing gases like oxygen
to enter and carbon dioxide to
exit these globular clusters can sense
vibrations on on the leaves they are
mounted
on and might hatch early if they detect
a predator
approaching amphibians like these
hourglass frogs lay their eggs on these
plants and it can take less than a week
for the young to hatch before falling to
the pond
below but a week is a long time in the
wild espe especially as these gooey
sacks of frog spawn are an irresistible
treat to many prowling
[Music]
hunters and one of them is Slithering
nearby
the caride
[Music]
snake the Frog parents are ill equipped
to deal with the
threat and in their defenseless State
the only choice they have is to
[Music]
watch but another dangerous Hunter close
by has other plans for the caty
snake the Grom whose stomach is still
empty after several failed attempts to
catch
food a tender snake would hit this
spot
the hungry Grayson eats that
glass and The Hourglass frogs are safe
but only for the
moment because there are things far
scarier than snakes in their corner of
the
rainforest death on eight legs stalk a
group of hourglass
[Music]
frogs and with less than an hour left of
night
they may not live to see another
[Music]
sunrise
this nightmareish Hunter is a Wandering
Spider and on this
promad she has many places to
hide and she safies her hunger with
insects and
amphibians
[Music]
the Frog sense the presence of something
close
by but this eight-legged Hunter knows
how to approach
[Music]
unseen
The Hourglass frog leaps away just in
time but there are other other options
is close
[Music]
by
the spider's venom contains a cocktail
of toxins that work by immobilizing her
catch stopping its breathing and
liquefying its insides by breaking down
cellular
structures
this creates a nutritious stew that she
sucks out of her
[Music]
prey having had her fill she wraps up
the left door
[Music]
s she heads back into the ring Forest to
scout for new hunting
grounds wandering spiders rarely stay in
one place for
long but her wandless brings her into
close proximity with a ravenous
[Music]
stranger
the king
toad one of the largest and toughest
Toad species on the
planet this amphibian is adapted for
life on the Mean Streets of the fourth
floor
he rarely returns to water except to
[Music]
breed he'll eat just about anything he
can fit into his
[Music]
mouth
but he's hopped right into the strike
zone of the
fillans and she isn't letting another
meal
Escape she hits the K toad with a
powerful
strike
but bony ridges on his forehead protect
him from her
fangs and he leaves her with a nasty
surprise the can toad secretes a nasty
toxin which stuns the snake and allows
him to
escape
just as da
arrives a vient night in the rainforest
reaches its
end and exotic bird songs celebrate the
return of the
Sun but its warm glow is no guarantee of
safety
and thousands of daytime Hunters prepare
to
[Music]
feed